welcome to Carnegie Mellon online for
more multimedia from Carnegie Mellon
University visit w WC mu edu slash
multimedia
hi my name is Paul Raphael and I'm from
Raleigh North Carolina I study painting
in filmmaking here at Carnegie Mellon
University production crew look I came
over and I met them and they're really
really very nice very welcoming and I
just kind of told my name and I showed
up at all the shoots and I've been doing
I've had a couple extra parts here and
there mostly in my residence hall and
daughter but I've also been working as a
closed set I've worked part of the crew
but mostly I've been Ashley just sitting
and watching and seeing how I do things
seeing how the director works how about
how the actors work I've always loved
film and it's only been maybe about a
year or so that I've really been kind of
into it and really want it to be to get
into the film the film industry and if I
had known about two months ago that I'd
be sitting next to Dennis Quaid or
Thomas Haden Church on on a set of a
major motion picture I wouldn't believed
it so coming here is this all just a
dream really and it's been great i mean
i can set people been really friendly
and i've been really welcoming and I
felt like I wasn't just an outsider but
they actually included the whole campus
and people been really excited it's been
great so I mean the learning experience
the connections I've made with people on
set learning how things are done how
shots are set up how the filling process
goes day in day out it's really
beneficial I'm really excited to be here
and just being on set is a thrill and
that's just enough for me